lorenzo dimmi tutto ci cattivo è svolta
che mi vedeva male mia fattoria che è
uno start un pochino più decente
rispetto agli altri
acri anarchici esatto berlina la
produzione italiana non la regola
dimmi tutto lecce gente devi venire
nella casa a destra con me non gli ha
posto meno in faccia gli eva mon amour e
in culo per me poi alla c'è gente vieni
per fuori da me perché a ci stanno
all'incirca a 67 di mela noi c'è un tipo
che arriva centimetri da ci va bene va
bene macchia tutto spaccando un po vai
vai ci riprova adattino aspetta no no no
no no ero tortona su terna su torna su
lukalu caduta avete guardato salvato la
vita
grazie ciccio prego
ok è buttato giù ma piace un altro è
andato da lei è bravissima ma la
partenza giusta lievito stato fatto
davvero il club e te lo dico e siamo uno
qua dentro c'è gente c'è una trappola
completato
io credo di averti salvato la vita
prende dirà slurp grazie io non ho
capito
ok non ho capito niente di quello che
studenti preoccupare baby poi tutto
tullio bevono avvenuto o siamo 2 a 1 è
di kill però tranquillo abbattuto uno
zio e 31 ammazzato 41 sto scherzando
dico io non lo faccio apposta
niente di qua
abbiamo strategia fatto roba da un po
così se stesse bene così ti ho portato
nel motel è una delle mie tante tappe e
molto buone quando le forze ci porti ai
ragazzi quanto non ha mia vita mi
parlava sinistra c'è una cassa prendi la
parete sopra vede la vedo vedo subito ma
mai [ __ ] alla cassa vi giuro lorenzo
ma quella droga proprio stacca fin cazzo
ci dà troppo buona come tanto non line è
anche vista la casa non è che visto
perché non sei dispone ma ci sta o ti do
ripartito io però la sento
sono molto contento la bomba ballerina
ma è utile sta roba
sì sì è utile se non hai altre armi
ancora più utili in mano si è utile va
bene limitava lanciano addosso se va
bene vedi abbiamo trovato l'utilizzo
allora chi di voi cosa scarna sega
grande come sempre come sempre
porca eva andiamo personali kronos
chiaro invece che stanno uomo sul cazzo
vedo un ambientalista meno di zero punti
zero o c'è un tipo classista c o per la
casetta nella hall del lago eccolo sotto
di noi sotto di noi proprio prova 120
l'acqua sotto davanti
eccolo qua lo vedi dentro la casetta è
sì quello che dicevo ok
minchia l'altro lavoro anche più visto
l'hai ucciso tu beh ecco la guarda vedi
l'ora equa questo è quello nuovo
guarda proceda capace ragazza questo qua
qua c'è un medico che quasi quasi se lo
stock e mi fa piacere lo stocco di
stoccare toccarlo con la s
significa ammettere che non sanno bene
che questa cosa ma incredibile 150 sta
nel fiume nella cee presento io non
sparo perché costa armato detto un po
particolare poi dobbiamo correre io ce
l'abbiamo appena scoline amo solo un pò
l'amo perché mi sa che da solo se non
cool amo amo nuovo amico mio
noi lo siamo milano ovvio che c'è in
groppa tutte e due
ecco noi anche ben trovati qua davanti
porca vacca il casinò
ho detto ho capito non servendo dai
maledizione è pro che ti devo dire che
mi ha sparato da torre dove la torre la
torre dietro ancora dietro l'albero c'è
una torre costruita così il fortino ok
ok camera se ci hanno cecchino corso el
i famosi famosi fa
loro non sanno con chi hanno a che fare
riproviamo sarà difficile ai a olio
madonna che presa ha colpito mezza volta
una sega servizio cioè ti becca destra
granara e magari c'è mori de tutta la
tua e joe jordan e ciop doppi l'ho
colpito perché ho io
ma letizia grande e bella bella era solo
lui si era solo uno stronzo si vai vai
la costa da bella melodia zio di questo
punto mi lasci le cose per terra non
fosse solo dio voi dal cecchino nonna
pia via ho trovato surreal power stock
al medico stop col medico
ok sto col medikit un hashtag che
aspetta e mitragliatrici ap la massima
uk farà con cui la sotto accordo non
saper né leggere né scrivere a sparare
ma allora non siamo messi male non
stiamo messi bene
colpite le mitra ce l'hai quello del
mitra dei colpi leggera amico guarda di
mi voglio milioni di iscritti prendi
guarda quale menisco parla a max arca
allora vai anche se è vero è come temi
come vini come vieni con me perché ce ne
dobbiamo andare a ma rimangono solo in
14 non avevo visto ok ok ok che è stato
mio vincere eccola retrocesse stanno
arrivando aspetta come di tiro sospetti
in giù gli alieni sono qua sto qua
tiramisù by vengo sulla scala come possa
offrire soffrire sono due time sia e
tutto ciò tutto ciò tutti
come se non esiste non esiste non esiste
ciao ci si sono buttati vai vai tu
rimani qua io provo a curarmi allora
siamo rimarca orali sono tutti morti
quelli di prima occhio a 330 c'è uno che
mastica da punto a cecchina dan fascia
madonna è forte sta davanti a noi
eccoli li vedo
una terra o grandi che si fa vuota team
così che si fa così cosa tu e tu stai a
25 davanti a noi 60 resta qui
è lui quello forte non io davanti a noi
ci esattamente davanti a noi
porca vacca quanta gente
è lo mandò al punto che il casinò 1 la
partita
non lo so e l'altro no io ho colpito un
bel po no è morto è morto bravissimo
bene bene e ragazze che ci siamo ok che
in famiglia c'era un po di scudo madonna
lega ma mamma mia mamma mia se vuoi
cielo gli scudi per te cielo 6 rimasti
rai tre team proviene prenderlo bazooka
beh bazooka è buono se vieni vieni vieni
dobbiamo andare dobbiamo andare là
ok si stanno sparando picchia comunque
non abbiamo fatto robe prodotte te lo
dico no no però mi trovo per quelli che
hanno tirato la cecchina da non erano
così stronzi stanno là però si stanno a
vedere tra di loro no non spari erano
andiamo un attimo si è poi conosciamo
sparare ma io non li vedo da tre stampa
costruire costruisce ed io sono partito
scherzavo è bravo salendo a c2 vada che
si stronzo
sono arrivato perché tre ore per os che
siamo contro quei due
volevi sei beccato non sono stato questo
a dall'albero cazzo virco peccato in
quanto ho fatto
quella crosta sull'albero è non c'è più
l'altro ci hai fatto bene si no ma ora
varcato anch'io non manca molto
tantissimo signore vostro andiamo
andiamo da lì ferma lì fermo lì fermo ma
andateci vieni vieni sia delle vittorie
che arrivava alla fip ha già il pirla e
come ok dov'è e io ho buttato giù un
tipo non so dell'altro
ma quali è buttato la femmina l'ho
buttata e mina signore perfetti è brutto
da di però è però sarà femmina ma la
malafemmina l'ho vista a certi
quell'altro show dove a va bene dove va
bene così sta lì ok grazie bottino per
noi ragazzi e il sotto il partito che
gioco con ciccio vinto tutte e tre non
lo so perché nei partiti lo hai fatto
scusi
14 4 nei fatti sul 10 in più il divario
che si dimezza qua peggiore so contento
sono contenti cat africano è piaciuto un
sacco e si è
[Musica]